love this guy he's one of the best
hitters in major-league baseball he's
one of our favorite guests whenever we
want to talk baseball and he's been kind
enough to join us here on the Rich Eisen
show from the Colorado Rockies the
four-time all-star Charlie Blackmon how
are you Charlie
hey rich thanks for having me back
please come on man you are always
welcome here
where have you sheltered in place
Charlie I am currently in Denver okay
and that way I feel like I am NOT on
complete vacation I'm here in my home
park
trying to stay focused trying to stay
ready because we don't have a whole lot
of information but hopefully that
changes tomorrow so what what are you
hearing what are you and your fellow
Rockies and also colleagues across Major
League Baseball you might be in contact
with hearing right now it so tomorrow
there's gonna be a meeting between the
Players Association leadership and Major
League Baseball and they're going to
discuss some sort of outline upon which
we can hopefully return to playing the
game everybody wants to play you know we
haven't had a lot of information the
past few weeks month we're just kind of
sitting on ready just trying to stay in
shape so hopefully this is the beginning
where we get the ball rolling and we
move towards normalcy well and in terms
of that we'll get to you how you're
staying in shape and how you've been
spending part of your quarantine in a
second you said everybody wants to play
you basically think you can safely say
your your colleagues your friends in the
game are like let's do this thing is
there a but a large but what do you
think no I am surprised at this point we
don't have any or we don't have more
confirmed cases among players in the
game you know where most of the players
are pretty far removed from New York but
all the you know all of the teams are
playing in major cities and and you
can't ignore the fact that there is a
pandemic going on but I know I think we
have the ability to
test frequently enough and and do our
best at isolating players such that we
can get going
a lot a lot of players have concerns you
know I'm I'm one of them I don't want to
get sick I don't want to bring people
together such that other people get sick
especially those that are at risk but at
the same time you know I'm not playing
I'm not getting paid
neither are a lot of people that work at
the stadium you know there's a lot of
people that depend on Major League
Baseball for their livelihood but bigger
than that it's it's you know this
country needs baseball we need to get
back to summer life we get back to
normalcy being able to watch live events
on TV you need that badly no I don't
blame you for saying that Charlie you're
spot on there and I just want to give
you the floor here and what you meant by
that you know that this country needs
baseball and the opportunity that
baseball does have here of having the
stage and taking it yeah I mean it when
was the last time you watched a live
event I mean so you watched the NFL
Draft and that was you know I've done
remotely you know it's just it's just
something that we we missed I think it's
it's crazy how many of my friends that I
talk to that are that are watching you
know reruns of old baseball game or you
know pretty much everybody burned
through the Michael Jordan documentary
you know anything that it's relevant to
current events in terms of especially in
the sporting world is going is is
important to our culture I know Charlie
Blackmon of the Colorado Rockies here on
the Rich Eisen show just a couple more
questions about this and then I do want
to just you know catch up with you here
so would you be fine quarantining if the
proposal comes to you that hey you will
have to go to a spot and spend at least
14 days there and then maybe the way
that we get through all
is that baseball settles in one spot I'm
hearing that that's not gonna be the
proposal that it will be actually where
you would be able to play in Colorado
and then figure out who can get to you
and where you can get to safely um but
if it's quarantine is that an issue
Charlie no that's not an issue that I
mean guys around the league work so hard
to get here if you were to say hey all
we have to do to play baseball is
quarantine you're like you know that I'm
not believe that and I at that that's
you know I'm quarantine right now you
know I'm doing everything I can do to
stay health healthy and safe and not
spread this to my teammates I mean it's
it's not something we haven't already
been doing I'm definitely prepared to do
that and did you take that antibody test
were you one of the many we took that I
had not taken it I have acquired about
it and it's a research and I know that
there are some tests that aren't as
accurate as they need to be charged yet
there are some tests that are better I
am going to try and get one through the
team through Major League Baseball we're
going to have to test everybody really
soon Marshall and so I'm I'm gonna hold
out until then I haven't experienced any
symptoms so I don't what what about you
in terms of your when you talk about
quarantine what what about some of your
colleagues who have lives and children
and things like that Charlie I mean is
that a problem about quarantining and
staying away from family members for
weeks months at a time that is a big
problem but you know I kind of fall on
the line of you know this is what I've
chosen to do and it's my life's work and
this is really important and it's also
probably why I'm pretty good at it so
far you know it's it's what I want to do
and and there's a lot of sacrifices I've
made I want to make some more sacrifice
to play the game in terms of my life
away from the field do I think there's
an ability to include your family and
within the quarantine yeah I think
there's some wiggle room there you know
significant others kids as long as
they're willing to
No be in quarantine as well you know
they can't be out on all over town going
shopping at the mall and then come get
you sick and then you go to the park and
get everybody else day but you know I
think that that might be a necessary
evil at least early on until we get
things figured out Charlie Blackmon of
the Colorado Rockies here on the Rich
Eisen show all right what have you been
doing outside of getting ready for the
campaign sir that we're hoping you
actually go and rake in what do you got
it's weird having all this free time I
tell you I'm usually very scheduled
especially this time of year you know
I've got travel in the next seven months
or planned out for me so in my free time
I've gone fishing I've got a new puppy
dog I've been doing a lot of work we'll
call it work a lot of videos promoting
terrible fundraisers in the in the
community
graduation videos I've done some
podcasts I did I recently did a podcast
with my friend Chad Belding who hosts
the foul life yeah Outdoor Channel yeah
Chad Belding right his podcast this life
ain't for everybody yeah you've done
that yeah he's you know he's a duck
hunter and that's what he shows about
like you know popular culture and
athletes and so he you know interviews
some guys on his podcast did one of
those I somehow managed to get this huge
chunk of time and then still feel like
I've squandered it you're not alone
charlie you are not alone so you know
like if you haven't become a concert
pianist out of this thing I understand
but have you have you have you been
watched any programs or you have you
done anything like that did you do the
tiger King did you do that or oh yeah
did the tiger King haven't finished the
Michael Jordan thing yeah okay there's a
lot of you know a lot of Netflix Amazon
Prime going on in our house I've
actually I've recently told my wife I'm
going to cut back on the Call of Duty
video games okay I was getting pretty
far down that rabbit hole
okay I'm now consider myself an expert
dog trainer after all the YouTube videos
that I've watched huh so you give the
Cesar Millan in you a little bit Charlie
you got a little bit of that going on I
like that
all right the beard Charlie we know what
it's like during a playing season I
imagine what it's like in quarantine
Charlie what do you got for me there
worst
it's haven't I haven't got a haircut a
beard round I mean since come on since
we know it's been a couple months now so
I'm I'm looking a little rough it's kind
of hard to hide this beard under a mask
situate like a respiratory situation
when I put the mask on I've got the
beard man so can we get a photograph a
current photograph of it would you mind
yeah taking one and tweeting it out at
Rich Eisen show for our record yeah we
can do that I've got some time what the
Denver Post is doing locally there
they're playing your games on MLB the
show 2020 and you had a hell of a day
yesterday are you wear that German yeah
do two home runs no idea you had two
home runs in there in their virtual
there's a great shot of you you know
from the video game and the beard is
clearly not what it is now cuz it's nice
and tight looks trim but you've raked
yesterday virtually so congratulations
just one virtual game at a time all
right so will you please at Chuck
underscore nasty please take out a
photograph of you currently and then
tweet it at Rich Eisen show and we will
we will share it with our our viewers
and listeners as well just to check this
thing out you got it
excellent I appreciate the time Charlie
and I hope I really do hope that what
happens and is presented to you and the
rest of your membership and the rest of
your playing colleagues is something
that everybody feels that we can do my
kids miss it man I miss it the country
as you said could really use
but obviously everybody's got to be on
the same page and be safe about it you
know yeah I just hope that our goal is
to get back on the field and play the
game right that's what we need that's
what that's what both sides want I hope
we don't get caught up in the politics
too much you know I just I would like to
expedite this situation and get back to
playing ball now when you say politics
you're not talking about American
politics are you just talking about the
internal oh no no I mean I that's a
whole nother show rich I'm sure it is
Charlie but I mean in terms of the the
inner workings of baseball I mean
everybody right I mean this is the
opportunity for the national pastime as
when I was a kid to get out there I
would watch any game any time any inning
any anything again if I'm understanding
that everybody's all on the same page
and it's not gonna get anybody harmed in
making the product you know I mean yes I
mean right up there with we need to get
back on the field and play we got to
keep guys healthy and then I just hope
those are the only two factors right I
hope we don't get caught up in money or
interest here they're on either side
that aren't getting on the field and
play in staying healthy I hope nothing
else gets in the way
Charlie me too I appreciate the time man
miss chat with you you're one of my
favorite guests certainly from the world
of baseball and you're just a regular
dude just trying to rake and make ends
meet and be out there for everybody so I
really appreciate it good luck let's
keep in touch thanks a lot rich right
back at you and I look forward that
photograph all right okay there we go
it's uh it's Charlie Blackmon hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here